video in a while I'm about to go and
work out to work out on my stepper I
listen to Ukrainian and I read the text
while I'm running for 25 minutes I do
that once a day but the subject today is
fluency
what is fluency how do we achieve
fluency I often get these questions and
other questions that relate to fluency
so first of all to me the definition of
fluency is very straightforward if you
are fluent in a language you are
basically able to express yourself more
or less accurately quite comfortably on
a variety of subjects you understand a
lot of what is said to you in a
conversation it doesn't mean that you
are perfect it doesn't mean that you
don't make mistakes you can be fluent
and still have that feeling that we all
have when you sit in a with a group of
native speakers and they're all speaking
to each other very quickly and you
understand a lot of it but when you want
to jump into the conversation and this
was a question I had I can't remember
from whom on the channel here you know
that it's difficult for me to
participate you know in these
spontaneous discussions and so forth and
you have to be very fluent and very
familiar with the culture to get into
these conversations where people are
making jokes and there's a you know a
lot of banter back and forth and you
want to jump in and say something but
you feel a bit of pressure because you
know you have to speak rather quickly
before somebody else jumps in and you
know interrupts you and says something
else that's difficult you don't have to
be fluent to be able to pull that off
fluid is in my opinion in most
situations one on one one on two you can
say what you want to say you understand
what
they're saying there's no strain in the
conversation someone in my opinion is
fluent when I am confident that they
understand what I'm saying
and that I'm able to understand what
they're saying and we have a comfortable
conversation that's fluent in my
business career I've dealt with a lot of
foreigners like non-native speakers of
English who make mistakes but who speak
English very well to my other fluid
no it's fluency the only measure of
success in language learning
I don't think it is because we all have
different goals you know if I look at my
languages which with Ukrainian now is
they up to 15
I can probably comfortably carry on
conversations in I don't know seven or
eight of them but when you get into my
more recent languages where I because to
be able to be fluent and to speak well
you have to speak a lot so if you
haven't spoken a lot in a language
you're not going to be fluent and I mean
a lot so my Russian my check which is
now a bit I mean very Russian
not to mention Romanian and Korean where
I haven't a chance German I haven't
spoken them much recently I would
struggle but certainly you know French
Japanese Mandarin Spanish Cantonese I
need to get warmed up into it Italian
the same way but it wouldn't take me but
a day or two to be comfortable but that
doesn't mean that I haven't achieved my
language learning goals for example I
mean in Russian if I listen now to you
know my interviews from aircon mostly i
understand essentially 95% of it that's
pretty good I'm happy if I watch a movie
I understand you know an Italian movie I
understand essentially everything you
know Ukrainian now when I got off get on
my stepper I read and listen I
understand
mind you I have looked at some of the
words when I say all there will be the
odd word that I'm not sure when I listen
to you know robots care radio from us
get audio podcast without the transcript
I understand a lot of it like it's it's
interesting for me it's interesting but
I miss the odd part so now in fact I'm
going to have some transcripts done up
which I will load up into link and study
so what I'm trying to get at is the
depending on your goals like I feel that
I have achieved in the two months or
less than two months and I've been at
Ukrainian I have achieved my goal in
that I understand now if I watch
television discussion I understand what
the politicians are saying when I speak
as I've done with Elena our Ukrainian
tutor and link I really struggle to
speak when we really want to understand
each other I switch to Russia but you
know I'm happy for what I've been doing
I'm happy I think I can say that you
know how many language do you know is
sometimes the question how many hours
did you speak I don't really speak
Ukrainian very well but I know it well
enough to understand what I want to do
with the language and I have the feeling
that if I went to Ukraine if I went to
Kiev or leave it wouldn't take me long
in other words if I were to go and spend
two three hours a day speaking on skype
I could bring up my level of spoken
fluency oral you know communication
ability I understand a lot some people
simply want to go to Mexico and order a
beer find their way if they get lost so
that's not fluency but if that's the
goal and you achieve that goal and
that's that's good so I think we should
in our language learning we should focus
on achieving those goals that we have
for ourselves but if the goal is fluency
then it is that call it you know b2 c1
and the European scale in my opinion
it's it's a hi love
of comfort it doesn't matter that you're
mistaken for a negative it doesn't mean
that you don't make mistakes
it doesn't mean that there aren't
moments when you don't fully understand
I think you can have all of those
shortcomings and still be fluid I think
to be fluent what's perhaps more
important than you know not making a
mistake or some person said to say
you're flowing you have to be able to
know the word for you know tying your
shoelaces or squeezing a tube of
toothpaste or some of these things that
that you're not gonna do because very
rarely you talk about tying your
shoelaces or squeezing a tube of
toothpaste so it's not realistic to
expect there's something that's rather
obscure all the way it may seem like an
everyday not very difficult thing to do
it's not likely to come up in the
average conversation that a non-native
speaker has and if it doesn't come up
they're not likely to know how to say
those things so I don't think that is
any kind of a meaningful test of fluency
fluency is that sort of level of comfort
and that's a B to a c1 level in the
language as something comes up all the
time if you have any questions or your
reer disagree don't hesitate to comment
now I'm gonna go and have my workout you
know while I was closing out that video
I had lost my train of thought I got
sidetracked into I was going to say what
really matters in fluency is some level
of familiarity with the culture and then
I got sidetracked into squeezing my
toothpaste tube and tying my shoelaces
but what I wanted to say sort of to
finish on this element of fluency and
why fluency takes time and exposure is
that to be comfortable in the language
comfortable talking with people
comfortable in social situations you
have to have some familiarity with the
culture which means probably a lot of
listening reading possibly exposure to
movies probably exposure to people and
lots of opportunity to talk to people
and that takes time to be
in a few minute so there again as you
know I'm not a great fan of this you
know 100-yard dash to fluency I think
you have to invest the time to become
familiar with to become immersed in the
culture and all of that contributes to
your feeling comfortable so that you can
speak with some confidence fluency even
though some of the fine points of
grammar or pronunciation or elements of
vocabulary or occasional you know
crossfire conversation you might find
difficult to understand okay thanks bye
for now